Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
We've been talking about a
bunch of different integration
techniques.
Here are a couple of examples on
which you can try and pick out
the right technique to compute
these two integrals with.
So I've got the first one,
is the indefinite integral
of x cubed times the
square root of the quantity
x squared plus 2 dx.
And the second one is
a definite integral.
It's the integral
1 to e of x squared
times the quantity ln of x
squared, with respect to x.
So why don't you pause
the video, take some time
to compute these two
integrals, come back,
and we can compute
them together.
So hopefully you had some luck
working on these integrals.
Let's start with the first one.
So for question A, let
me just rewrite it here.
We have the integral of x cubed
times the square root of x
squared plus 2 dx.
Now, if you look at this
integral, what you see
is a product of two terms.
This term is x cubed.
It's a nice term.
This one is the square
root of x squared plus 2.
That's not such a nice term.
There are a few different things
you might think to try here.
So one thing you
might think to try,
is this square root
of x squared plus 2 is
the sort of thing that shows
up in trig substitutions.
So that's one thing you
might have in your mind.
Another thing you might
have in your mind,
is that this is a
product of two things.
So you might consider
the possibility
that you're going to do an
integration by parts here.
And the third thing you might
have in your mind is just,
you could just-- you
know, this might just
be a substitution situation.
You have this x squared plus 2
as the sort of discrete entity
that shows up there.
So you might try a
regular substitution.
Now you have to, you know, make
a choice among which of these
to try.
And it seems to me
that of those options,
a regular substitution
is the easiest to do.
And you'll find
out really quickly
whether you've made your life
horribly complicated or not.
And frequently, with
integration by parts,
if you have the option of doing
a substitution when you have
integration by parts, you
know, it won't-- if you do
the substitution, you still
can do integration by parts
afterward.
If you do integration
by parts first,
you can still do the
substitution afterward.
So trying the substitution
shouldn't hurt us
for integration by parts,
and a regular substitution
will be a lot simpler than a
trig substitution here, right?
Trig substitutions in
general are complicated,
so it's a good idea to see if
there's something simpler that
can be done first.
So if we're going to try
regular substitution,
the sort of natural
thing to do, is
to set u equal x squared plus 2.
So in this case, we have
du is equal to 2x dx.
Or-- well, so OK.
So we want to substitute
these things in.
The u is going to go into
the square root term.
So that's going to
be taken care of.
And the dx part--
well, we've got an x
here to pair up with the dx, so
that's going to give us a du.
And then we'll have
x squared left over.
So we'll need to substitute
in for x squared.
So we're going to use x
squared is equal to u minus 2,
and x dx is equal to du over 2.
So when we make these
substitutions in here, what
we get is that this integral
is equal to the integral
of-- so it's x squared times
the square root of x squared
plus 2 times x dx.
So that's u minus 2
times the square root
of u times du over 2.
Now, having made the
substitution, we see-- OK.
So with a little bit
of rearrangement,
this is just a sum
of powers of u.
Right?
We can rewrite this as the
integral of u to the 3/2 over 2
minus u to the 1/2 du.
And now, this is just
straightforward to integrate.
So it turns out we don't
need integration by parts.
We don't need a
trig substitution.
Just this regular
substitution works nicely.
So we get, well, u
to the 3/2, so we
compute an antiderivative, so
that gives us u to the 5/2.
And I have to divide by 5/2,
so I have to multiply by 2/5.
And then I have a half.
So it's u to the 5/2 over
5, minus-- so u to the 1/2,
so that gives me 3/2, so I
need minus 2/3 u to the 3/2.
OK.
And now to finish
this off, I have
to do my final
back substitution,
and replace u with x.
So this is going to be
x squared plus 2 over 5
to the 5/2 minus 2/3 times
x squared plus 2 to the 3/2.
All right.
Plus a constant.
Thank you, peanut gallery.
Right.
Indefinite integral,
should have had it
right the very first
time I went through.
Plus a constant, both times.
OK.
Good.
So that's all there
is for part A. Now
let's look at part B. So OK.
So part B is a little
more complicated-looking.
Let me copy it over here again.
So part B, we have the
integral from 1 to e
of x squared times the
quantity ln x squared dx.
So again, there are a couple
of possibilities for what
we could want to do here.
One thing is you could try
just a regular substitution.
So maybe a regular
substitution you
might want to try is u equals
ln of x, or x equals e to the u.
And now if you try that, you
can try it, and what you'll see,
is you'll get something.
So here we have a
polynomial times a function
of the logarithm, a
power of the logarithm.
If you try that substitution,
what you'll end up with
is a polynomial in u
times an exponential in u.
So OK.
So it's not clear that
we've won anything,
if we make that substitution.
The other thing we can try,
is we can try integration
by parts here.
Again, we have a product form.
And if you make
that substitution,
you get polynomial
times exponential,
and that's also a promising
place for integration by parts,
after the substitution.
So OK.
So I'm not going to
make the substitution.
I'm just going to go--
seeing this product,
I'm going to go for
integration by parts directly.
So I need to decide what pieces
are which for integration
by parts.
And the thing to
remember is this
that-- so I have here
a polynomial times
a function of the logarithm.
And the thing to remember
is that polynomials
like to be differentiated.
That's their preference.
But logarithms really, really
like to be differentiated.
You'd much rather differentiate
a logarithm than integrate it.
You can integrate a
polynomial-- I mean you
can integrate either of them.
You can integrate a polynomial.
When you integrate
a polynomial, you
get something that's still
a fairly nice polynomial.
Integrating
logarithms is harder,
whereas differentiating
logarithms makes them
into just powers of x.
So setting this up as
an integration by parts,
we're going to
want to take this,
the everything with
the logarithm in it,
and that's the piece we
want to differentiate,
to try and simplify it.
So that's going
to be our u part.
So we're going to try
u equals ln x squared,
and that leaves v
prime to be x squared.
So to do integration
by parts-- OK.
We need to differentiate
and we need to integrate.
So if I differentiate ln
x squared, I get u prime.
The prime is equal to-- OK.
Well, this is a
little chain rule.
So it's 2 ln x times
the derivative of ln
x, which is 1 over x.
And if I integrate
v prime, I get
v is equal to x cubed over 3.
OK.
So now I use the formula
for integration by parts.
So I have that this integral--
what I'm going to do is
I'm going to call this,
let me give it a name, I.
Now I'm going to come down
here and I'm going to say,
I is equal to-- well,
by integration by parts,
it's equal to u*v minus the
integral of u prime v dx.
So in our case, u*v is x cubed
over 3 times ln x squared.
But the thing to remember is,
this was a definite integral
to start out with.
It's from 1 to e.
So when you take
this part out front,
you have to take the
difference of its two values.
So we're going to evaluate
this between x equals 1
and x equals e, minus
the definite integral--
so we still have a definite
integral from one to e
of u prime v. So
that's 2/3-- OK.
So now we have an ln x
over x times x cubed.
So the x and the x cubed,
that cancels one power
of x out of the numerator.
So we're left with
2/3 x squared ln x dx.
So.
One thing we see,
this is just going
to be-- this is just going
to evaluate to a constant.
We're going to plug in e,
and we're going to plug in 1,
and we're going to
take the difference.
So that's just some number.
This part is still
some integral.
Are we done yet?
Well, it's not obvious
immediately how
to integrate this.
I mean, I don't already
know off the top of my head
what the antiderivative here is.
On the other hand,
it's definitely
simpler than what we
started with, right?
Before we had x
squared ln x squared.
Here we just have
x squared ln x.
So we've simplified
the integrand.
And it's still in a form in
which we can further integrate
by parts, if you wanted to.
Right?
So now in this case
the natural thing to do
would be very similar
to what we did before.
We're going to take
the u to be the ln
x, to be the piece
we differentiate,
and we're going to take
the v to be x squared.
OK?
So we can do that.
So this is equal to-- let's see.
I'm going to bring
it, now, upstairs.
So this is equal to-- all right.
So we plug in e here.
We get e cubed over 3 times
1, minus when we plug in 1,
ln of 1 is 0.
So that just gives
me e cubed over 3
for the first part
minus-- all right,
and I'm going to pull
the 2/3 out front.
So it's minus 2/3 times--
OK.
So now I'm going to
do an integration
by parts on this one.
So again, like I said, I'm going
to take u is equal to ln x.
I'm going to take v prime
is equal to x squared.
So that means u
prime is equal to 1
over x and v is equal
to x cubed over 3.
And so again, I get uv,
which is x cubed over 3 ln x,
and again, because it
was a definite integral,
I have to evaluate this between
x equals 1 and e, minus-- OK.
So minus the integral
of u prime v.
So this is the
integral from 1 to e.
u prime v is 1 over x
times x cubed over 3,
so that's x squared over 3 dx.
OK, so having written all
that down, what you see
is this is a constant minus 2/3.
OK.
This is just some constant.
We'll plug in e,
we'll plug in 1.
That's easy.
And now we have an integral,
and we've reduced this finally.
Here we have just an
integral of a polynomial.
So an integral of a polynomial,
that's easy to compute,
you can do it yourself.
And I'm going to let you finish
off the last couple of steps
for yourself.
In the end, the
answer should work out
to 5 e cubed over
27 minus 2 over 27.
This is what you should
find the final answer
to be when you work it all out.
So I'll end there.